[Música]
por que a adoção como que uma mulher
venha ao mundo e não quer gerar um ser
em seu vent e os filhos de vocês vem
quando nossa é tão linda
ela tem mãe
nossa como seus filhos são fofos de ó
eles têm família
essas são algumas das perguntas que uma
mãe que não tem um filho biológico
escuta todos os dias eu sempre fui uma
mulher que achava que o relógio
biológico nunca é despertar
eu nunca havia pensado em ter filhos e
isso veio com muito questionamento
crítica e também com muita pressão de
alguns amigos e família como que uma
mulher venha ao mundo e não quer ter um
filho da sua barriga
hoje eu vejo que essa é uma convenção
imposta pela sociedade e que mesmo que
comum não
não são todas as mulheres que querem e
desejam isso pra si
depois eu comecei a ser questionado do
porquê eu optei pela adoção sim porque
foi uma opção da qual me orgulho muito
mas como toda a escolha feminina ela
veio cheia de questões do tipo
tadinha nossa mas ela já é casada há
tanto tempo e ainda não tem filhos e
junto com isso eu li e ouvi em muitos
lugares que eu era estéreo
não gente
eu não sou estéreo e nem o meu marido
mas obviamente há dúvidas sobre
exterioridade veio sobre mim que sou
mulher e não sobre ele que é homem o que
é muito sério porque justificando dessa
maneira a sociedade nega que uma mulher
não queira ter filhos biológicos ou
então nega que uma mulher não queira
explodir a sua barriga de vida e
acredita em frente
existem diversas outras maneiras de
explodir vida da gente é bom
a minha vida mudou completamente desde
que meus filhos entraram nela mas hoje
vou falar mais especificamente sobre o
meu primeiro contato com a maternidade
que foi com a minha filha de somo tudo
na minha vida mudou desde a primeira vez
que eu havia desde a primeira vez que eu
abracei ela
eu me lembro até hoje da sensação de se
engasgado na garganta e do meu corpo
trêmulo e eu pensando meu deus o que é
isso que eu estou sentindo que
sentimento é esse eu encontrei a minha
filha ea minha filha me encontrou foi
numa viagem a trabalho e que de repente
tudo na minha cabeça sumiu ea única
coisa que eu tinha certeza certeza
absoluta é que eu queria protegê lá ea
mala pro resto da minha vida e eu sabia
que ela era minha filha eu sentia eu sei
ela é a minha filha eu não sei
exatamente como que é o sentimento de
uma mãe
quando pega o seu filho pela primeira
vez depois do parto mas eu arrisco dizer
que esse sentimento é muito similar com
o que eu senti ali porque o meu parto
ele foi naquele chão frio daquele abrigo
no meio de pessoas que eu não conhecia e
que a única coisa que me importava na
vida era eu e ela
o sentimento que eu tinha era que só ela
me conhecia e só eu conhecia ela foi ela
que me tornou mãe foi ela que me tornou
leoa
afinal não é assim com todas as mães
entre entre tantas bilhões de
possibilidades uma só criança nos
escolhe seja ela no útero ou seja ela no
coração
e aí começam as várias barreiras que a
adoção quebra e que nem a ciência pode
explicar a vocês sabem aquela famosa
frase ah tá no sangue
ai puxou o pai ae a cara da mãe pois
essas acham que minha filha não escuta
isso ela escuta muito e todos os dias
sabe porquê porque ela é minha cara
ela tem o meu olhar ela tem o meu
sorriso
ela tem os mesmos gostos que ele tem
todo meu jeitinho
a adoção é muito transformadora
o que a sociedade precisa entender é que
a adoção é sim sinônimo de maternidade e
que a adoção assim como a gestação é
muito transformadora da sociedade
entende isso não
muitas pessoas não entendem e se o pior
tem gente que acha que a adoção é um ato
de caridade e não é eu voltar sempre
aqui lembrando a vocês ea todos que a
adoção é sim maternidade ou paternidade
e eu vou pedir com todo o meu amor e
toda minha gentileza que por favor não
façam perguntas constrangedoras a uma
mãe adotiva que isso dói muito
perguntas como o filho de vocês vem
quando vocês podem imaginar que a única
pela única resposta que eu posso dar
para essa pergunta é
ela já veio ela ela minha filha eu
também já houve nossa jogo como é linda
mas ela tem mãe oi tem eu sou mãe dela e
também tem essa nossa como eles são
lindos
ele tem família
é claro que ele tem família
ele tem a mim que sua mãe ao meu marido
que é pai avós primos tios e aí vocês
vão me perguntar como eu fico numa
situação dessa e como que eu fico quando
eu sou questionado dessa maneira eu fico
muito machucada todas as vezes
mas eu tento ser forte eu tento sem
pática e eu tento principalmente
compreender as pessoas que ainda não têm
um entendimento do que é a dádiva da
adoção
eu sei que eu sou uma pessoa pública
eu sei que a minha vida noticiado e
comentada pelo público e eu sei também
que a partir do momento em que eu tive
os meus filhos
todo mundo começou a me relacionar eles
normal e comum ok
mas o que não é normal é que a imprensa
acaba esquecendo que eu também tenho uma
carreira profissional e assim começaram
a me chamar para trabalhos e reportagens
desde que os meus filhos estivessem nas
fotos o que com o meu marido que é homem
e só obviamente não aconteceu
eu neguei praticamente todos esses
pedidos e mesmo assim eu vi em alguns
lugares que eu queria aparecer
ela quer aparecer pra mim é a frase mais
cheia de julgamento que eu poderia ouvir
na vida e vocês sabem por quê porque
essa frase é preconceituosa
essa frase é preconceituosa porque o que
faz uma pessoa achar que o meu amor
pelos meus filhos não é real ou então
que meu amor pelos meus filhos é menor
do que o de uma mãe biológica
essa frase me mostra a incapacidade
humana de amar e para essas pessoas que
continuam falando coisas desse tipo eu
só vejo uma incapacidade de amar e de
olhar para o próximo
já as pessoas simpáticas
essa me fazem tão feliz porque elas me
param todos os dias na rua pra contar
histórias de amor história de adoção
histórias de encontros de alma assim com
o meu
isso é tão lindo eu me arrepio
freqüentemente lembrando dessas
histórias e aí vocês vão me perguntar
claro tá mas e aí não tem um lado ruim
de ser uma mãe adotiva tem claro como
para todas as mães compra todos os tipos
de mães
nós todos temos muito medo o medo é
constante mas eu tenho algum
os medos além dos habituais de uma mãe
que teve uma gravidez comum
eu tinha muito medo de quando a minha
filha me perguntar se uma mãe de barriga
eu nasci mas esse eu já superei graças a
deus mas eu ainda tenho muito medo de
quando os meus filhos começarem a ter um
entendimento melhor sobre a vida começar
a me questionar sobre adoção sobre o
passado sobre a história deles o
presente porque o fato é que muitas
pessoas acham que uma mãe adotiva não é
legítima mas eu sei a mãe que eu sou eu
sei a mãe que eu procuro c e
principalmente eu sei que a minha
relação com os meus filhos vai ser
sempre muito transparente e muito
sincera
então eles sempre vão saber da história
deles do passado deles e do presente
para que no futuro isso não seja uma
surpresa e também porque eu quero que os
meus filhos saibam que é importante para
que toda criança saiba a importância da
sua ancestralidade e que saibam que o
amor é sim um agente de transformação
eu costumo dizer que a minha barriga
mudou de lugar e que o meu parto
ele veio antes da gravidez
eu falo que a minha a gestação durou um
ano e meio mais ou menos e que foi de
muita dor e de muita angústia porque é
diferente de uma gravidez comum
eu já conhecia a minha filha eu já sabia
que ela gostava de manga que ela tinha
medo de passarinho e que ela era muito
linda tinha um olhar muito curioso é que
ela queria muito sair daquele lugar para
desbravar o mundo comigo
e são esses momentos
me fazem ter certeza de que a
maternidade nasci em outro lugar que a
maternidade nasce de um amor profundo
intenso e que de repente só para no seu
ouvido e você já é mãe
e aí vocês vão perguntar mas você não
tem vontade de ter um filho de sangue e
eu vou responder
não existe laço maior no mundo do que o
amor e não tenho como responder essa
pergunta pra vocês agora porque hoje eu
não tenho esse desejo
isso pode mudar talvez o meu coração eo
meu corpo disserem que sim mas hoje o
que o meu corpo e meu coração me dizem
exprimem o tempo inteiro é que eu já sou
mãe e que eu sou uma mãe como qualquer
outra que ama que protege que educa que
ensina e que tem muito medo
a minha relação com os meus filhos
sempre vai ser pautada nessas três
palavras transparência sinceridade e
amor porque eu acho que com toda mãe tem
que ser assim
obrigada obrigada
[Aplausos]